[Music]
oh kim don't knock him over as you can
see kim
is beyond excited to see usman in person
for the first time and apparently
he likes what he sees you know it is way
better than what i was expecting you
know like she looked good but
things take a slight turn when his
assistant slam t uses
password
all right super fun don't call me that
well she does have his face on her shirt
but you're super fun no i don't know no
no no i said i don't i don't know
one thing is for sure
kim is a woman with a lot of love to
give and if you already thought she was
going the extra extra mile for useman
this episode
she ran the distance
[Music]
yes
we'll get into all the ways she's
cashing out with hopes of making oozeman
fall in love
plus
i've even used my vibrator really yeah
ella goes into extreme detail about her
sex life with her boyfriend johnny
and it just has me wondering it's too
much information
not a thing anymore i get to watch his
face make all these weird
faces while he is touching himself
wow
okay
hey baby i miss your lord uh love you
hi 90 day fans fam it's melisa i
appreciate all your holiday wishes last
week
it touched my heart hi tuxedo yes okay
thank you now let's talk kim whose heart
is currently on the line usman still
considers me his potential girlfriend
i'm hoping that on this trip i can
convince him to be in a relationship
with me because i want a future with
usmen in america this episode she
arrived in tanzania for usman's music
video shoot a day before he arrived from
nigeria is this the hotel yeah this is
so excited to see it once she gets to
the resort which is beautiful by the way
she reveals she booked the honeymoon
suite
but she's staying by herself and let's
keep in mind that this is also a
two-week trip usman and his team chose
this beautiful resort so i decided to go
a little bit above my means and book the
honeymoon suite because i have
intentions here
usman is staying in his own room because
he wants to take things slow
but i think after we spend some time
together by the end of this trip he'll
be in my room
oh my gosh this is beautiful
oh my
god tomorrow night he will be on that
balcony with me i think champagne is in
order right i think so girl
those expectations will set you up for
disappointment i read this quote the
other day that said sometimes we create
our own heartbreaks through expectation
isn't that the truth
then we get mad at the person who
disappointed us and they're sitting over
there confused like what did i do
i've learned if it's not official don't
allow your imagination to run too wild
shoot even if it is official
you just have to learn to let it flow
okay kim
all right girl i'm so excited i'm
shaking the next day kim gets all cute
and ready to go meet her potential aka
uzman at the airport and oh yeah she
decides to take him some roses
if a lady gave you roses would you feel
weird about that
yes
really he was straight up honest now i'm
nervous to give him the roses kim goes
on to say that she's putting everything
on the line for oozman including
spending money out of her savings
account and leaving her mom
yet i'm not sure if oozman has
sacrificed a thing
kim joining him on this trip seems to be
about convenience he was headed to
tanzania for the music video shoot all
he did was tell her to come along i'm
going to have a heart attack it's going
to happen as kim was anxiously waiting
uzman hops off the plane with his team
do you think your super fan is here
no don't call a super fan just have fun
she's here usman ends up telling his
friends to wait as he went to meet
kimberly face to face for the first time
and boy oh boy i bet his ego was stroked
nicely that day
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
when kim hands him the roses he actually
says he likes them
do i look like me and when it comes to
uzman's first impression of her
here's what he has to say
you know it is way better than what i
was expecting like is that a compliment
she looked good
she looked good we're cute together
right i don't like 50 what
no no you don't look goofy oh oh you
look like tied to 1 32
now i am all about us woman feeling
great about ourselves but
ooze man you look like tattoo one tattoo
too
i love him all right fast forward to his
assistant and manager meeting kim i'm
kind of nervous about meeting them
because i don't know them don't worry
about them hi super fun
don't call me that
super fan
but you're super fun no i don't no
he still calls her a super fan after
uzman told them not to so do you think
you're super funny here
no don't call us super fun it's
interesting how everyone's instinct is
to call kimberly a superfan
because that's what it comes off as
i definitely called her one the other
week
kim
is also a super fan
don't call me that my bad girl
kim why don't you like to be close to
buffalo when they get in the car slam
tea
his name is so fun to say it sounds like
you should be on wwe or something
anyway when they get in the car slam t
brings up the super fan convo again
and things get heated i'm more than a
fan now you know so what are you now
what do you think what do you think you
are right now
i mean i'm here like he invited me here
to watch the video because i am a fan
you know what i'm saying he invited you
but he told he told me that you wanted
to come told me that you wanted to come
so i'm kind of confused right now
but i'm not going to argue about this
with you guys wait wait wait i invite
this woman here but you shouldn't have
to like make her feel like
her you're asking us stupid questions
i'm not gonna take that i will not i
said listen listen please i'm not gonna
take it oh okay okay copy of course that
made kim feel real good i really don't
care what badminton slams you think
about me being here because i'm here
and the fact that usman stood up for me
really shows me that he does care when
they get to the hotel they chat a bit
but eventually go their separate ways
but kim set up her room all nice and
romantic for oozman to come over later
that night and i hope that when usman
sees all the romantic decorations that
he'll get the hint and want to stay in
my room tonight it shouldn't be the
decorations that prompt him to stay
it should be you
when usman gets to her room the
decorations and the room itself actually
concern him
do you like that we did that dude they
did it this is like the honeymoon suite
this is like the best room so you'll get
the honeymoon yeah i mean i felt like i
was coming here to meet you we don't
know what's going to happen yeah but
like you said honeymoon do you know what
no no we're not weddings honeymoon
always come
after the wedding well we're not even
whoa let's not talk about the marriage
kim
now we know you want to talk about the
marriage i want a future with usmen in
america but i get it i can't even act
like i've never done something like that
before don't hate the player hate the
game kimball's room you know like
it was well set up like you know so
romantic but it kind of too much because
like
i'm not a boyfriend yet kim went and got
the most expensive room in the hotel
with hopes that it would pull oozman in
but he's not budging
i would be thinking
wow
i just really wasted this money
well i want to give you your guess
speaking of money kim tells oozeman she
has some gifts for him and what's under
that white towel
i was not ready for
no
she she wasn't ready
one two three go
[Music]
how much does a macbook pro cost
a thousand plus
is it used you tell me yours broke oh my
god so i got it for you kimbally
are you for real i am for real i love
you okay i'm thank you thank you for
other gifts
no
[Music]
how much does a ps5 cost
[Music]
buying love that's not the way to go
[Music]
if it's real his love shouldn't have to
cost you a thing
i would think she would want him to fall
in love with her for her no no no
and back to expectations
is he now going to think that kim gives
random gifts the type of gifts you give
your husband better yet your kid
you're really a potential right now
that's like girlfriend status right
there and he still called her potential
that's like girlfriend status right
there you know what i'm saying almost
from telling you what you said
thank you
he said almost
honestly that's sad
that sad i know no one told her to buy
those gifts but
the feeling of going above and beyond
and it's still not being enough
sucks
was giving more play to the ps5 than he
was to ken and i'm sitting over here
like hello can i get some of that this
i'm gonna pass the night today
are you gonna sleep let's sleep with
that instead of me that's cool this is
something i will never forget i'm i'm
telling you that this is something i
would never forget i know
but
i'm sorry i'll be going back tomorrow
but i do appreciate this gift honestly i
know you don't
even though i am sad usman's going back
to his room tonight
you know over the next two weeks we're
gonna be together every day he made that
clear and that's super important because
i only have two weeks to convince him
that i am the woman for him
she's taking this on as a challenge to
convince oozman of her worth
and as someone who has felt the need to
prove my worth to a man before watching
her go to these extremes is tough
in my opinion this isn't so much about
how much she likes oozeman but it's more
about the lengths she would go to to get
oozman to desire her
there's a difference
my name is ella i am 29 years old and i
live in idaho falls idaho alright moving
on to ella who gave us all the tea
on her sex life with her boyfriend
johnny who lives in china
and if you're confused about what
exactly ella was doing here she explains
how she loves to dress up in cosplay and
embody her characters
today i am a soul reaper and i am here
to reap your soul if you had enough
she also opens up about her overall
obsession with asian culture hence while
she decided to get an asian man i think
japanese movies were really a big
inspiration like the samurai movies i
love just how they looked in their
samurai outfits with their long luscious
hair their eyes their face their skin
tone
i love everything about them
okay so i found a social media page
called asian men white women
and that is where i found my asian
prince ella has been dating johnny who
was a 34 year old single dad for a year
and a half
hey ella it's johnny i hope you have a
great day
but due to covet restrictions she hasn't
been able to travel to china so the plan
is for johnny to get a travel visa and
visit her in idaho in a little over a
month
hey girl hey you're here
in the meantime she has lunch with her
friends and opens up about how she and
johnny are keeping the passion alive
virtually
you do know that i've i've never been
naked
on video chat and i have with him
you did well
i was i've been
we have our sex yep
you know he's a boob guy i'm sure he
likes them oh he loves them he's he's
gonna lose his when you see something
through santa gets to touch them oh my
gosh our video chats are basically
me playing with one of my beautiful big
boobs and i get to watch his face make
all these weird
faces while he is touching himself wow
i was not trying to picture johnny doing
that and ella continues
i've even used my vibrator really yeah
fyi it is very hard to film that
her friend is exactly me right now
because i don't know what to say
all right let's move on to next week it
looks like kim is going to get a little
bothered by usman's business meeting
with another woman there is some lady
she's an artist and she heard that i'm
around so she went to me
so i know why you're here but why is kim
here
i'll flip the table and i'll walk out i
don't deal well with shady oh
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]